okay well it's my great pleasure to
introduce my buddy Mike who knows way
more about the Maine heavy than I do in
watch
thank you precaution thank you to the
other organizers for inviting me to
participate in the program it's really
marvelous to be here I've been very much
enjoying the lectures so far and look
forward to the rest of the week and
again my apologies for renaming the
program as Val pointed out it was
unintentional
so Vikash asked me to talk about domain
theory and measure theory and I thought
what I'd do is give you a brief primer
on domain theory at the start and then
try to point to some classical areas in
probability theory and measure Theory
some of which you saw just an hour ago
with Prakash's talk and point to the
links between them and the domain
theoretic approach to measure theory so
to start to start no thank you
now it's on okay to start the the goal
for the talk then are to give you a
short primer on domain theory and then
talk a little bit about the classical
approaches to measures and probability
much of which Prakash covered but
there's some ideas that I think what
bear mentioned that he didn't talk about
and then tell you about the domain
theoretic approach and then talk about
some applications and the applications
I'll refer to are some recent ones one
of which refers relates to dana's
stochastic lambda calculus that he
talked about on Monday so what is a
domain well it's really a rather simple
structure it's really a partially
ordered set with some added properties
but what I'd like to do is emphasize
that
it's the way you interpret that
structure that's important from a
computational perspective in particular
think of the partial order is something
that's in formatic so one elements below
another if it has less information so
the more information you get the higher
up you are in the order and a nice
example of this that's not really out of
the programming language perspective and
directly is to think about zero finding
think about the bisection algorithm so
you have a continuous function that is
defined on an interval and it changes
sign how do you go about algorithmically
finding our zero for the function well
the bisection algorithm says you look at
the left half and it changes signs on
that then you choose that if it doesn't
change sign on that half it has to
change sign and the other half and you
use that and it's deliberately
deterministic because you've chosen the
left half by priority but you could do
it by the right half first if you wish
but then what you're doing is you're
really worrying about the intervals
you're looking at and saying one
interval is more informative and than
another if it's smaller than the other
interval so it's this reverse order of
containment that's important in this
example and also notice that this order
is on the data not on the function it's
about what the domain of the function is
and the data that's being affected so
that's an example of a an informatics
partial order and then presumably if you
iterate this process enough times if you
divide the interval if we use the
bisection interval algorithm you divide
it in half some in a number of times and
eventually you'll get to some interval
of length 0 which is a point and that's
the 0 you've been seeking of course you
have to have conditions to make sure
that's going to work but in the
hypothesis I stated it would work the
second idea is how do we get to that
shrinking family of intervals what does
that mean well it's an expression we
call directed completeness and the
notion is based on an idea of a directed
set a directed
in a partial order is a subset D that's
not empty and given two elements in it
there's a third one in the set that's
above them both so think of that as
talking about consistent information you
have two elements in your partial order
you'd like to know are they consistent
well if they're in a directed set then
those two have something above them so
there's more information than both of
them and that means that those two
together have some consistent
information and directed completeness
says well if you have a directed family
then in fact in this partial order
there's a least upper bound or a soup as
we call it okay so any consistent family
of information will have a least upper
bound that's the the information all of
the elements contain now those two
things together will give you what are
called directed complete partial orders
and indeed that's enough to do a lot of
things people use that but what we
haven't talked about is any kind of
computability we haven't really said
what it means to be computable or
something that you have to know in some
finite time and that's what the role of
approximation is so we use this double
less than you could read that as X
approximately
whenever you have a consistent family of
information that contains as much
information as Y contains then at some
point in that consistent information you
already contain what X contains and that
contained that really captures the idea
of the X if you compute enough to get Y
at some finite stage you have to have
already gotten X okay and that's the the
notion of as we're calling it
approximation but actually compute
ability if you like in a finite time
embodied in this theorem and here
well I skipped over this part that for a
directed family of intervals so a filter
basis as its called
the intercept of the soup soup is just
the intersection and here this
approximation is the idea if an
intersection of a filter basis of
non-empty closed intervals the
inside an open set then one of them is
and so that's how our approximation
works the interval a B approximates CD
if CD is in the interior of the interval
because that's an open set and then CD
is the intersection of all of the closed
intervals that contain it in its
interior in their interior okay that's
this expression of anything any closed
interval these are bounded intervals of
the umbria of course is the intersection
of a filtered family of open intervals
whose endpoints are finite that contain
it okay so this isn't the usual typical
example but it's one that shows you that
domain theory has more to say than just
about syntax of programming languages
and denotational models okay any
questions on this so this is what
domains are there structures that
satisfy these three properties okay know
what's going on so okay so
Prakash said he would category five if
that's a word what's going on and I'm
going to make some references to
category theory but I promise not to
really get into the weeds but I do want
to use the word morphism where our
function and so if we have these partial
orders these domains what are the proper
notion what's the proper notion of a of
a mapping between them
well mappings mathematically ought to
preserve the structure so they're
partially ordered sets so the map F
ought to be monotone and I call them D
continuous for directed continuous
because I want to know that if I take a
directed subset of P then F of the soup
of D is the soup of F of D so F
preserves this structure of taking the
least upper bound of a directed set so D
obviously here's the sub set of P and
I'm calling these D continuous because
this is just talking about the order
it's got nothing else mentioned here
although we'll see another version of
this in a second and we could talk about
DCP oh the category apologize for the
word directed complete partial orders
and the
the continuous maps and one of the main
theorems for the fundamental theorem if
you like least fix point semantics is
the tarski connector Scott theorem and
folky on really gave a nice illustration
of its use earlier today but it says if
you take a directed complete partial
order that has a least element which we
usually denote by perp or bottom and a
monotone self map then that monotone
self map has a least fixed point F and
it's gotten just by iterating the
function at bottom bottoms below
anything so f of bottoms above bottom
and halves monotone so when you start
iterating you get an increasing family
and eventually you're going to run out
of ordinals because the set D only has a
certain size and once it starts
repeating then you've reached the least
fixed point phone really used that in
his example all about data log this
morning this afternoon rather and then
the the Scott contribution of this was
this idea of continuity that if it
preserves deep reserve soups of directed
sets you don't have to iterate forever
in fact in countably many steps you will
have reached that list at least fixed
points okay and this is the heart of
what's called least fixed point
semantics and if you think about
unwinding recursions in process algebra
simple unwinding formula is that say Rec
X dot P unwinds to P applied to rec X
dot P for X and what that's really
telling you is the recursive process is
a fixed point of the body and so this is
where at least fixed points why you want
fixed points and least fixed points to
face one comment that that folky on made
was well you know there could be a whole
family of fixed points which one should
you pick in fact our squeeze theorem
which applies in the lattice setting
says if you take a monotone self map of
a lattice that means where you have any
pair of points have an upper bound and a
lower bound and still directed complete
then in fact there's a whole family a
whole lattice sub lattice of fixed
points for any such map the least one
has gotten by inter a
at bottom the largest one has gotten by
iterating atop and that winds down and
all the other ones are somewhere in
between the sublattice that those two
found but not every point in that that
region from the low of least fix point
to the greatest one is a fixed point but
that was tar skis theorem in the lattice
case and Canasta did a topological
version of it and then Dana's
contribution was this realization that
continuity really told you something
about computability like should I focus
on finance try to construct using the
operator is continuous because extension
qualified quantification and it's
actually distributed right so that's an
application that that about crosses in
omega steps okay okay so everybody here
knows this stuff so why are you letting
you talk about all right oh well that's
another talk okay so properties data
mentioned this in his talk that if you
take a function from a product of D cpos
to another that it's jointly D
continuous as I'm calling it if and only
if it isn't it's in each variable
separately that's a very nice result you
know in in real analysis for example
that is definitely not true you you have
to struggle to get joint continuity for
a function even knowing that it's
continuous in each variable separately
if you take the set of maps from P to Q
that order then point wise that is f is
below G if and only if at each point f
of X is below G of X then in fact this
is another directed complete partial
order and the soup is just gotten by
computing so point was computing the
supreme implies and this is another DCP
oh and again there are Clarkie cartesian
closed categories of domains these this
is not a category of domains because it
doesn't have the approximation property
but this in sitting inside our nice
categories of domains and one we were
taught
talking about before the meeting today
is bounded complete domains where every
pair of elements has an infant about
every non-empty subset has an int and it
often happens that you don't need
lattice structure this is quite enough
to do everything you want so I've given
this definition in a part with respect
to partial orders but in fact there's a
completely topological way to do it so
this is going to bring precautious wine
glasses into the picture so he's waking
up now so let's call a subset you of a
partial order P Scott open if it's an
upper set and notice by the way the
arrow is on the left here so it's the
upper set of U is the set of X such that
there is it U and u such that U is below
X and Prakash wrote as arrows on the
other side so I'm just putting out I'd
prefer writing them on the left this
thing as an operator and the second
property is its cot open if it take a
directed set whose soup is in you then
the directed set already has to
intersect you so as Peter Johnston said
the Scott open sets or upper sets that
are inaccessible by directed soups is
another way to say it so this is always
a T naught topology given two points
there's a Scott open set containing one
but not the other it's in fact a little
stronger it's called what's called sober
I think that terminologies due to docker
but what it really means is that you can
retrieve the the space from its lattice
of open sets or its lattice of closed
sets that's really what sobriety is
telling you if you insist that you have
this idea that between for any two
points there's an open set around either
that doesn't contain the other that's
the T one property frame where two
topologist that implies that your order
is flat nothing compares with anything
else and so it it trivializes so these
are the structures you really want and
domains are sober although never mind
and then the proper limits topologically
are exactly Suprema
and they are applied for directed
that's the topological view of this
structure and in fact a mapping between
P and Q is D continuous as I've defined
it here if and only if it's Scott
continuous in this sense so what I'm
really telling you is this domain has
the property it encodes this topology
directly you don't need some extrinsic
application of it you can define it
internally in the domain and that's a
nice property because it says you can
either do it or order theoretically or
you can do it topologically we say D is
a domain well that means it also has the
approximation property and then the set
of points that any element approximates
turns out to be a basis for the topology
these are Scott open sets why are they
Scott open well they're Upper sets
because of what's called the
transitivity relation if X is below Y
and Y approximates Y prime but Y prime
is below Z then X already approximates Z
and that tells you these sets or upper
sets and it also has what's called the
interpolation property if X approximates
Z you can in between approximate Z by
something that X approximates and those
are exactly the conditions you need to
show that each of these sets is Scott
open and then they give you a base for
the topology because everything is the
soup of the things that approximated
okay all right so this is all internally
encoded in the in the domain structure
it's nice nice topological structure you
can use there is another topology I want
to talk about the Lawson topology these
names by the way were invented by karl
heinrich hoffmann who is a collaborator
in this area and he liked to name things
for people and so he named the scott
topology for scott and the laws into
polish apology for jimmy lawson who's
another collaborator for various reasons
so if you look at the scott topology you
notice it's every open sets an upper set
so if you know about Nachman z-- theory
of compact ordered spaces the open sets
consists of open upper sets and open
lower sets and then you get all the open
sets as intersections of them that
apology has to be what's called order
convex so what's missing in this
definition if you want a better topology
a finer topology is you need to know
what are the open open lower sets and
here I'm alluding to them by saying a
basis for the Lawson topology is take
the basis you have for the Scott open
sets these set of points that a given
point approximates and then throw out
finitely generated upper set so F is a
finite subset of D so I'm really saying
the open lower sets or compliments of
finitely generated up ourselves so if
you wanted a picture of one if your
domain look something like this here's D
then here's a finitely generated upper
set that looks kind of jagged like that
so F the consists of this point at that
point that point in that point I've
thrown them out and now here I have a
point little X and I look at its way
upper set so it might look like that so
I'm throwing this set out of that and
then I'm getting order convex sets in
that way and it turns out that in a
domain this is always a house Dorf
topology it's a very nice topology but
it doesn't have all the properties you
want for computation but it's useful in
some aspects and we'll say a domain is
coherent if it turns out that the loss
Anthropologie is compact so then you
have a nice compact hausdorff topology
to work with which is a sort of happy
hunting ground for people who really
want to prove some nice theorems
topologically all of the cartesian
closed categories of domains have
objects that are coherent in that are
compacting the loss in topology so they
all sit inside the category of coherent
domains and Scott continuous Maps those
are the appropriate ones but
unfortunately the coherent domains are
not Cartesian closed there's not an
internal hum so it's really it's the
obvious category you'd like to work in
but it just doesn't work so sorry about
that
ok so about what about some examples
well one example is the unit interval
where you order it in the usual order
and then what about approximation what
is X approximating Y well here a
directed soup well it's a chain so
any sets directed any pair of elements
has to compare and so when you take a
soup you're taking a soup of an
increasing sequence and then you need to
know if X is going to approximate Y well
if the soup gets above Y then eventually
it has to get above X well that's just
saying either X was 0 and there's
nothing to really prove or X is strictly
less than Y because then the soup of a
of a family getting above Y certainly
has to eventually get above X we can
take the interval domain instead of
taking all of the real line and their
reverse containment I can simply
restrict that to the intervals within
the unit interval and I get the same
ideas you can actually do this kind of
an example in topological spaces take a
locally compact hausdorff space like the
real line for example or RN if you like
and look at the non empty compact
subsets of X these are going to play the
role of the intervals that we were
looking at in the real line and then say
that one of them a is below another if B
is a subset of a again getting smaller
is giving you more information narrowing
down on the information about some
property you're looking for and then a
approximates B again if B is contained
in a interior and it's the same theorem
from topology that tells you this is
directed complete because you know that
theorem that says if you have a filter
basis of compact non-empty sets whose
intersections in an open set
one of them's in the open set in fact
this generalizes directly to what's
called the upper power domain in the
domain you look at the non-empty upper
sets that are compact in the Scott
topology examples these upper sets of
finite sets that I already talked about
if you take any finite subsets of D and
look at its upper set that's certainly
an upper set by definition and it's
compact because if you cover each of the
generators by an open set you've covered
the whole thing because remember Scott
open sets or upper sets and because of
that this family of non empty Scott
compact upper sets under reverse
conclusion it's a DCP oh but why well
there's a famous theorem by somebody and
Hoffman that says if you look at the
Scot open filters in the lattice of open
set so what do I mean by that the
lattice of open sets are the open sets
ordered by inclusion a filter in a
lattice is an upper set with the
property that any two elements in it
have a nymph in there well if you take a
family of open sets that's an upper set
that means any open set in there has the
property any a larger open sets already
in there and the filter property says if
you take two open sets in there the
intersections in there then what are the
Scott open filters those are the ones
where if you have an increasing family
of open sets and it gets in the filter
the unions in the filter then one of
them's in there how could I construct
such an object take a compact set and
look at all the neighborhoods of it
because of compactness if a union of
open sets covers a compact set finitely
many do but the families directed so one
of them does that gets the fact that
this is Scott open and in fact the
theorem says every Scott open filter is
accounted for by a Scott compact upper
set that's one of these families and
that correspondence leads directly to
the same theorem you use here in
topologically to say that whenever you
have a filter basis of compact non-empty
sets whose intersections in an open set
then one of them must be so that's the
theorem you need to say that this is in
fact a DCP oh and in fact the domain
structure follows as well from that so
that's just there on that tag line okay
so this is a nice generalization of a
natural idea in topology back to domains
that give you one of the so-called power
domains of the which allow you to model
non determinism okay so any any
questions all right another point I want
to make is about what are called domain
environments so the idea was if you're
going to do some computation on a space
say you have a Polie space where your
computations taking place you'd like to
embed it nicely in a domain and use the
domain structure to do some aprox
nations from computing and so the
setting for this is what are called
maximal point spaces an idea first
studied by Jimmy Lawson or at least
explicator I think he's yeah he's the
one who'd just define these spaces so
the idea is take a mat risible space and
look at as well accountably based
bounded complete domain so that means
there's a countable base for the
topology and it's bounded complete means
any pair of elements has only a greatest
lower bound and the question is could I
realize X as the set of maximal elements
what's an example of that well think
about this case I'm sorry this case up
here where we have the non-empty compact
subsets of a space X under reverse
inclusion X appears in there as the
maximal elements the points and that
mapping sending an element of X to the
singleton in here actually is an
embedding topologically from here into
the inherited toss Scott topology on the
maximal element so that's exactly the
kind of setting we're thinking about
here I'd like to know what spaces I
could I could realize in this way and
this is bounded complete because any
compact pair of compact sets the union's
compact and so that's your in
cooperation here there's a theorem
doodle Jimmy and a trio of authors that
says a space M has the property there is
sorry a space X has the property that
there is a an M that is accountably
based bound a complete domain for which
X can be realized as the maximal
elements in the inherited Scott topology
on the maximal elements if and only if X
is a poly space so that says that
there's a nice way to build domains to
represent them in a setting where you
actually can do computation because
these bounded complete domains that have
a countable basis are built for that
kind of kind of modeling
that's that's also true yeah they're
polish so this is its polish it's it's a
separable topological space that's
separable that has it's completely
mature izybelle so there's a complete
metric that's generating the topology
okay yeah okay so those are exactly the
spaces you can realize in this way okay
okay so now I that was my brief but if I
looked at the news hour my brief but
spectacular premiere on domain theory so
again if you have any questions I'd be
glad to try to answer them if I haven't
lost you completely in the chalk dust up
here or whatever this is okay all right
so I'd also I'm gonna put these slides
up but in fact I'm going to give put up
a longer version of them Prakash
convinced me I had enough for three
lectures so I've reduced it to enough
for two but and we'll see how we do but
anyway I'll put up a longer list and
there's also a long list of references
at the end so at the least think of this
as pointers to things to look for in the
literature about how these things work
okay so now what I'd like to do is
recall some ideas from measure theory
and probability and Prakash actually
gave a nice presentation of what I would
call the Kolmogorov view of measure
theory this was in the mid 30s when he
came with the ideas of talking about
probability spaces using probabilities
as set based functions and measure
algebra so Sigma algebra to to define
them and he also defined the notion of a
real variable at that time but there was
another strand of research that also led
to realizing measures and probability
measures and that's largely due to
Banach in the early 30s who had these
ideas about Banach spaces and the key
point there was this idea of looking at
a metric space a complete metric space
and looking at the bounded continuous
functions from X into the reals and then
taking the Banach space till the space
of continuous linear functionals
from this space into the reals and
that's the dual space and and the Rhys
representation theorem tells you that
there's an isomorphism between the
measures on X and this family of linear
functionals and the probability measures
are the unit sphere in what's called the
weak start apology the topology you get
on this from the the structure of the ad
Banach space you started with and the
Bayaka law glue theorem tells you that
the unit ball here is weak star compact
and so the unit sphere is as well and
the unit ball is what Prakash was
referring to as the sub probability
measures the unit sphere is the
probability measures but in fact in this
setting the weak start apology is the
same as the weak topology so a sequence
of measures in this converges weakly
probability or sub probability measures
converges weakly to MU if and only if
integrating against any bounded
continuous function gives has the
integral of f d mu n converges to the
integral of f D mu okay so that's one
strand that I wanted to recall if you
don't know this then this is something
to look for it's part of the functional
analytic if you like view of how to get
your hands on measures and I want to
call recall two theorems neither of
which Prakash mention well I think he
kind of alluded to this one but not
directly didn't really say it in
certainly this is one of the basic ideas
that simple measures so these are convex
combinations of point masses Prakash
talked about those we talked about
simple functions but I'm talking about
simple measures so put point mass at a
point and take a convex combination of
those where the sum of the coefficients
here is 1 they're all non-negative and f
is a finite subset of the space X these
turn out to be weak star dense in the
probability measures okay and if you
make this sum less than 1 then you get a
family that's weak star dense and the
sub probability measures so that's one
of the nice results that comes out of
this theory the other is the portmanteau
theorem that says
there's a collection of ways to think
about how measures converge weekly so
it's equivalent that mu n converges to
MU weekly or integrating against any
bounded uniformly continuous function
you get the integral the F D mu ends
converges to the integral of f D mu and
then these two that I've highlighted in
blue are set theoretic conditions one is
that the Lim soup of MU n of F is less
than or equal to MU of F when f is
closed and Dulli this is just by
complementation really limit of MU n of
oh is greater than mu of O greater than
equal to MU of O if u is open those are
two equivalent conditions and then the
last condition is one that's often
included is the limit of the MU n of a
is mu of a for any mu continuity set a
and mu continuity set is just to set a
such that the measure Mew of its
boundary is zero that's the topological
boundary okay so these are all
equivalent they give you nice different
ways to think about how convergence
works in the weak topology which is
arguably the most important topology on
probability or sub probability measures
so I just wanted to recall those because
I'm now going to talk about a domain
theoretical u of of measures and try to
bring in some of these ideas and show
you how they're related so on domains
how do we think about measures well if D
is a domain or just a DCP Oh in fact
let's let Sigma sub D denote its family
of Scott open sets then we'll say a
mapping mu is continuous valuation on
the Scott open sets into the unit
interval if it satisfies a strictness
property that it's measure of the empty
set is zero it satisfies modularity that
the measure of the Union plus the
measure of the intersection is the sum
of the measures it's also the same as
the inclusion exclusion principle if you
like it's monotone so that if you as a
subset of V then Mew of U is less than
or equal to mu of V and if you have a
family a directed family of open sets
then it's continuous in the sense that
mu of the Union
of the directed family is the soup of
Moo of the you is okay so this is the
Scot continuity if you view this lattice
of open sets ordered by containment okay
and this is an idea that arose just in
lattice theory the idea of evaluation
the trick here is to add this Scot
continuity and then you get a connection
with measures and it's easy to see that
any Borel sub probability measures
induces evaluation here you just check
it out it's not hard to see that these
conditions will be satisfied for sub
probability measure the converse was
shown by Jimmy Lawson for the countably
based case of bound and complete domains
but Alvarez Minea at a lot and saw he
Jeremy proved it for domains in general
so these are really the same thing as
sub probability measures that's what's
being said here you can view them in a
domain theoretic way as valuations so
what we do in domain theory is we refer
to V of these evaluations on D again
ordered point wise that's this
monotonicity condition reflected here
and we want them to be Scott continuous
because that's usually what you want
with domains you want Scott continuous
Maps and this family sits inside the
continuous Maps from the UM sorry from
Sigma of D there should be a sigma of
d201 it's a sub DCP oh but the domain
structure as as I'm saying here very
elusive it's very hard to understand
what that domain structure is okay so
now what I want to do is I want to try
to convince you that this somewhat
strange-looking way to represent
measures it's I guess it's not so
strange in light of this observation but
I want to relate it more directly to the
classical ways that Prakash talked about
and that I just mentioned and show you
that there really is a close connection
so one way is how do i how do I get this
order in a functional analytic way if
you think about the way things were
defined a few slides ago we used
integration against functions that's the
portmanteau theorem for example was a
way to test things that was the weak
conversions
if you think about inequalities it's not
hard to show that if you try to say that
Miu is below new if integrating against
any function continuous say you get less
than or equal to you discover that only
time measures can probability measures
compared is when they're the same okay
so it just dies however there is this
nice theorem that if you take a coherent
domain and sub probability measures then
the following are equivalent that Mew is
below new in this point wise order that
I just described or integrating against
a Scott continuous function from D into
the reals so I'm in giving the reals the
Scott topology what are the open sets
well on the reals the open sets on our
ears are like this an open set is a set
from A to the right and that's the Scott
topology on that it's not directed
complete but that's okay we can still
use it and I can talk about the maps
that are Scott continuous and I can say
that integral of F D mu is less than or
equal to the integral of F D new for any
Scott continuous map and that's
equivalent to this condition or I'm
talking about a coherent domain so I
know in its loss in topology it's in
fact compact and hausdorff and then I
could ask what about this for monotone
loss in continuous Maps well one thing
to note is the Lawson topology says on
the reals throw out the upper set of a
finite set so you're going to throw this
out well now you're going to get an open
interval and so the Lawson topology on
the reals is just the usual interval
topology and now you're talking about
monotone maps that are continuous from
the Lawson topology on D to the usual
topology on the reals and on the
non-negative reals I should say in both
these cases and then if you have this
that's the same thing as saying this so
this is very much in the spirit of the
functional analytic view of how you
would generate say a partial order and
it gives you the same one we're doing
with domain theory so gentleman lives in
that world the crucial result that
really well we we thought it really
would open up the Pandora's box of what
the structure of the sub probability of
probability domains are from a domain
theoretical and point was the work of
Claire Johnson her thesis in 1989 I
think Prakash mentioned this but the
idea is how can I compare two simple
measures mu and nu that are sub
probability measures when do I know one
at mu mu is below nu and her answer is
that this is true if and only if there
are transport numbers now F and G here
are finite sets so there have to be
transport numbers indexed by the pair's
X Y and F cross G so that Rx is in fact
the sum of the TX Y's the transports so
everything that R has gets shifted to
some point in this measure the sum from
over all the X's of the input incoming
weights from points are X is less than
or equal to the weight on any Y and if T
XY is positive then X has to be less
than y less than or equal to Y so let me
draw you a picture
which explains why this is a max-flow
min-cut application so let's take a
point over here and talk about this as
the source let's take another point over
here is the sink and now what I'll do is
I'll put F here so here's X 1 here's X 2
here's X sub n say where that's the last
element in F and over here all this G as
Y 1 y 2 y n ym and now what I'll do is I
will put arcs from the source to each
one of these and I'll label it with the
weight and so that's our n and now I'll
put arrows from each of these to the
sink and I'll label these
with their weights then the idea is this
is a transport problem I've got these
weights coming into these nodes that
represent the weights on each of the
nodes I've got these weights going out
of these representing the weights on
each of these nodes they have to get to
the sink what's the maximum flow I can
make here in what way well I can only
draw an arc from an X to a Y if X is
below Y okay so I might have X ones
below y2 and it might be below Y N and
x2 is below y1 and it might be a little
something there and so on for each of
them and then the transport numbers the
TX Y's are exactly the way to fill this
in so that you get a maximum flow and
the answer is you can do that exactly if
there's a min cut okay
everything politics
yes
actually this this should be a less than
or less than okay for sub probabilities
okay this should be strictly less than
not less than or equal to okay because
on sub probabilities you only know that
the weights coming in should be less
than what you have okay cuz that wasn't
your question though right well here Bo
because all of the mass has to leave all
of it has to get moved up you have to
account for all the mass on the lower
one CMU is the lower one so all its mass
has to go up okay you know all of it
arrives but it doesn't have to account
for all the possible mass above it I
mean you could have for example a very
simple example you could take one half
point mass at bottom and you could if
you had a top you could take point mass
at top and then the half would go up and
account for one half of this but you'd
have some left over right okay and then
this same argument again this should be
a strictly less than here but in the the
way below relation the approximation
relation then you need to say that if T
XY is greater than zero then this is
strictly less than and X is way below Y
and you do need strict lessons to get to
get the approximation that mu
approximates knew okay okay
so so again this is just a transport
problem and max-flow min-cut
characterizes when you can solve it and
so that's the that's where you get these
numbers okay all right
so this encodes in a very simple way how
this order works on simple measures and
it was thought at the time that this
would really unravel all of the strange
structure that exists on sub
probabilities in terms of the domain
structure in that family but in fact no
just yes whatever you want to do it
really hasn't we
in a second it really doesn't it's given
us a lot of information but not what we
really wanted to know okay so one of the
theorems I mentioned about probability
measures and sub probability measures
was the simple measures are dense we
have the same result here but I need to
define a basis first though a basis for
a domain is a subset which the property
that the set of things that approximate
a point in this subset is directed and
the soup of that subfamily is X so they
account for enough approximants for
every point and then you can argue that
any domain if you take a basis for it in
this sense and you take any basis so for
example the rationals in 0 1 then
forming simple measures over finite
subsets of the basis for D and elements
are X in your basis for the interval
this will give you a basis for the sub
probability measures so you have a Bice
nice family of sub probability measures
that any measure can be recognized as
the directed soup of a family in there
ok and you can even set this up so these
things actually do approximate things so
if you know enough about the structure
of the simple measures you know the
structure of the space in general ok so
this is an analogue of that theorem I
mentioned in the case of topological
spaces that the weak the simple measures
are weak weak dense ok so now there's
some series of papers by auguste add a
lot in which he tried to exploit these
ideas and I want to mention some
connections that arise that really
reflect these ideas in the portmanteau
theorem you remember that was the
theorem that said here are equivalent
conditions for weak convergence and one
of them was exactly this kind of a
condition on all open sets but we're
talking about Scott open sets so what he
showed was if you have a countably based
domain and a sequence of measures in
that R sub probability measures then
it's equivalent that in this domain this
is a domain now
I can talk about it Scott apology the
muons converge to Mew then the limit of
mu n of any Scott open set is greater
than or equal to mu of you that's
exactly the same condition in the
portmanteau theorem except we're
restricting to Scott open sets and a
corollary of this is that if you take a
separable metric space and an embedding
as the maximal elements of this D so
that it's a G Delta then that lifts to
an embedding of the probability measures
on X into the maximal elements in the
sub probability measures with respect to
the weak topology so that says that this
is the point of the same Scott is weak
on the top was the idea that you embed
these in probability measures as the
maximal elements the top elements in
this space and they inherit from the
Scott topology exactly the weak topology
from measure theory that result actually
was generalized a bit in some work I did
with Frank von Breugel jola Joaquin and
Ben world in which we accounted for the
other half in the case of accountably
based coherent domain namely you see the
two conditions now not just the limit of
un of Scott open set U is greater than
equal to MU of U but also the Lim soup
of this type of a closed set the upper
set of a finite set that should be a mu
N sorry is less than or equal to MU of
the upper set of F so here are the two
conditions that the portmanteau theorem
says and actually just from this result
you can then show that if D is coherent
so is the set of sub probability
measures the domain of sub probability
measures in the Lawson topology because
it agrees with the weak topology and
that's just the portmanteau theorem
because the portmanteau theorem says in
the weak topologies this spaces is
compact in the Lawson topologies
hausdorff and the map is one-to-one so
it's a homeomorphism okay so again what
I was doing here was just trying to tell
you that the conditions in one of
fundamental results the portmanteau
theorem do appear in domain theory and
give you some some nice results sorry
okay so I've been alluding to this
mysterious structure on the sub
probability measures again a little more
category theory it extends to us an endo
functor that is a monad you just push a
measure forward um given a map from P to
Q you just take a measure on on P and
push it to Q by this formula which is
the same one that Prakash use I'll
generally denote this by F so lower star
of Nu so that means push the measure new
on P forward to mu by saying F star new
of a measurable set is nu of F inverse
of that set so here's a almost
everything we know about the domain
structure of this functor V it takes
coherent domains two coherent domains I
just showed you a proof of that if you
take a rooted tree so a binary trees say
you know infinite then the sub
probability measures on that is a
bounded complete domain that's that's
nice if you take a finite tree that's
upside down turn it upside down but
finite then that's in another
subcategory that's cartesian closed
that's it that's the only structure we
know domain theoretically so it's kind
of disappointing this structure was
meant to model probabilistic choice P
plus of RQ which is a process that's
supposed to fuse P with probability R
and Q with probability 1 minus R the
problem with it it doesn't play nice
with with other structures we don't know
of any cartesian closed category of
domains that's invariant under this it
doesn't satisfy a distributive law so
this is some category speak to say that
if you try to combine probabilistic
choice and non determinism and I do
differentiate the two then you don't
have a nice way to say what you're going
to get there is there is a result that's
out there that
talks about some laws you generate but
they aren't orthogonal you'd like them
to be orthogonal you'd like to say
probabilistic choice is really different
than non-deterministic choice and you
could think of them separately and they
don't interfere
we don't have nono models that to
reflect that so that actually led to the
idea of doing random variables and I
want to spend the last part of this talk
the last ten minutes as it were talking
a little bit about that this is some
some very recent results and it will get
to dana's ideas but in a much more
general way so Prakash talked about a
infinity for an alphabet egg this was
the set of finite and infinite words
over a in the prefix order the simplest
example well not the simplest you could
take a one letter alphabet and it's
really simple but if you want an
interesting alphabet in fact one that
seems to have a lot of computational
weight to it is take the finite and
infinite words with zeros and ones in
them bit words and order them by prefix
so then you get this nice rooted tree
the empty words at the bottom the first
level is heads or tails 0 1 the next
level is outcomes of two flips of a coin
the next one as three and so on as you
work your way up the chain so if you let
there's an infinity missing here these
slides are really a mess if you let the
infinite words you think of them as the
Cantor set the usual middle third Cantor
set sitting at the top the topology you
usually give to the Cantor set is is the
inherited Scott topology so if you take
these wineglasses that Prakash talked
about that's the the upper set of a
point that's finite that's a Scott open
set and only for finite sets and what it
intersects with in the in the Cantor set
is an interval and that's the way you
get the nice interval on the don't
topology on the Cantor set of infinite
words but you can look at any level the
set of em bit words and think of those
as the outcomes of M flips of a coin and
if you're thinking of modeling of
computation that's doing this then
that's the frontier at which
computations are doing things you're
flipping coins for some number of times
one of those outcomes occurs then a
random variable will take that outcome
and give you a semantic value for it
that's the the intuition of what's going
on here an interesting point about this
structure is that you can collapse the
whole Cantor tree all the finite and
infinite words onto the set of words of
length at look at most M this tree
structure says if you want to take a
word up here and send it down what do
you do well it's a tree so there's a
unique path to the root so there's a
unique path there's a unique point with
exactly M words on it that's below this
point and every point has that property
that's the retraction and these maps you
can actually say are continuous in the
Scott topology this is a nice closed set
in the Scott topology and between any
two of these if M is less than n then
there's a projection from the end at
words to the N bit words and it's doing
what you think it just truncates the
word to the first n bits okay so that's
all very nice and intuitive so what a
student of mine did was he talked about
looking at this as a model of
computation so talk about the what are
called full antichains the set of M bit
words are an antichain no two of them
compare think of that as prototypical
it's also a closed set there's it's
finite ended so it's closed in the
lawson topology and it's full because
every word in the cantor set has an M
bit word prefix so it's upper set
contains all of the Cantor set and he
ordered these so the fullness is just
the Cantor sets containing the upper set
and he ordered two of these by saying M
is below and if M is below and in the
eglee milliner order which means
everything in M is below something in N
and everything in N is above something
an M or said another way there is a
projection map that takes n on to M so
every word here has a prefix in M and
every word in M has an extension in N
that's the order you want and then he
called this family his family of
random choice possibilities and the idea
here is you take one of these anti
chains of possible outcomes of some
number of flips of coins and then a
mapping that maps that's possible out
that set of possible outcomes to the
domain D that's your semantic domain and
what it represents is the choice you're
going to make if you get a particular
outcome in M as the outcome of the flips
of coins then X will tell you what value
to take in D to associate to it and
again order these by this order on the
anti chain part and assume also well
that this mapping X on the smaller anti
chain when you project the N bit words
down to and down to M and then followed
by X you get something less than or
equal to Y and he showed this is a monad
it's a monad on the bounded complete
domain so it's very nice computationally
and it enjoys a distributive law so it
behaves nicely with respect to non
determinism with least the upper power
domain now daya's model on Monday he
talked about P of n the power set of the
natural numbers as a model for
computation and he all of his work was
done in that model that was his whole
universe and his randomness was a random
variable for the interval to P of n so
Tyler's monad generalizes it here's the
syntax of a language that's called
randomized PCF for those of you who know
PCF is the simply typed lambda calculus
Overground types of naturals and bulls
and function types and then here's all
the syntax that you have true/false 0
successor predecessor testing for zero
if-then-else variables lambda
abstraction application recursion and
then this is randomized choice and that
he and Tyler instantiates using this
monad and that's how he he achieves a
model for in fact this this structure so
his construction actually allows you to
model randomized algorithms
it's interesting because it feeds the
outcome outcome of the random tosses to
both a process so for example if X is
testing a prime P whether a number P
whether its prime and Y is testing say
some other prime Q and you want to know
whether P or Q is for prime then you fit
you feed the same random choices to x
and Y to test whether P or Q is on prime
and it implemented this and in fact
there's an implementation on github and
it works it's really nice it gives you a
nice model and this was what Dana was
really hinting at the idea that this
sarcastic lambda calculus could give you
some some way to model and randomized
algorithms in this domain theoretic
approach okay so the last thing I want
to talk about is some more recent work
domain environments were ways to embed
topological spaces into particularly
nice domains that's a set of maximal
elements and then seek to approximate
Scott context between x and y with Scott
continuous maps that approximate them
between the model for X and the model
for y and some work I've been doing
recently has been looking at this in a
way to approximate measurable maps on
the maps that Prakash was talking about
and for that I need to say a little bit
more but a stochastic process is just a
family of people like say a time indexed
family of random variables where each
random variable is from the same
probability space into s where s is a
Polie space so I mentioned that before
and there's a remarkable theorem that
I've been just intrigued by for some
time called score odds theorem and it's
fairly easy to explain it says if you
take any holy space these are the spaces
that probably list at as possible places
for random variables to take their
values and you take any probability
measure on it then if you let lambda
DeNoble a the bank measure on 0 1 there
is a measurable map from the unit
interval with the Burrell sigma-algebra
as a measure space to s so that the push
forward of lebesgue measure is the
measure you started with it's kind of
amazing it says no matter what measure
you start with any this is for
probability measures on any Polie space
you can account for it just by knowing
lebesgue measure and a measurable map
moreover if you take a sequence of
measures on on s and the measure mu nu
such that this sequence converges weakly
anew then the random variables that
you've chose have the property that the
push with the push with the property
that the push forward of lambda under X
was new and the xn push forward of
lambda was new n then these x ends will
converge to X almost everywhere with
respect to lambda so this is not only
telling you you can get each one with
the push forward in the map but in fact
the the random variables you choose have
to converge almost everywhere so this
reduces convergence in the weak topology
on this abstract measure space of this s
here to convergence of measurable Maps
almost everywhere ok and what I've
managed to do recently is to prove this
theorem using some of the structure that
can this cantor tree you know it's a
little late so I'm not going to go
through this but the interesting point
is you have to construct you do it by
approximating the measures new n and new
n plus 1 you approximate new with these
measures and you find simple measures
that do this approximation and you
construct functions with the properties
you want just for each of these simple
measures and then the thing that you
need to make sure that you get an
increasing sequence here is exactly the
transport numbers that I talked about
from the splitting lemma from Jones so
it's very nice it says you can get any
measurable map in this way in fact the
corollary to the proof is if you take an
embed a Polie space in a nice domain
environment and you take any
measurable map from the interval to s
then in fact you can say F is almost
everywhere equal to a G where G in fact
is the soup of what I call piecewise
constant maps these maps that I
constructed using the the splitting
lemma
okay that's that's enough I've got like
three slides of references that'll get
put up plus a lot more elaborate version
of these slides so let me let me stop
here thank you any questions yes to the
extent that the way you can get these
mappings is constructive yes you'd be
able to say that so if you have
enumerated a basis in particular in the
in the context of this this corollary
here if this MS was done in a way where
you could enumerate the basis then this
you would be butdo approximating simple
measures there and you could conceivably
constructively do things okay
I hadn't I hadn't worked through that no
but I'm I can't see why yeah yeah I'm
not claiming it's it's true I'm saying
that yeah if you if you enumerated this
structure a basis for this structure
then you should in principle be able to
do it but there might be a big
now on the score HUD well there are lots
of proofs of this in fact they're
generalizations and they're they're like
point-set topology if you ever looked at
that where you pick points and you but
you're you're in measure Theory world so
it you don't have to worry about open
set so much you just need measurable
sets and so you can throw things away
and you do it sort of in a nice way but
it's very it's no pun random how you
choose the points okay so so in a sense
what this is doing is say there there is
a sort of algorithmic way ya know it's I
don't think that's the I don't think the
Tyler used a continuation style
semantics he used sort of a standard
semantics for this and then just
augmented it by feeding feeding the same
stream he didn't he didn't split the
stream that way that Dana was doing it
by saying will you get this one that I
don't know any of these semantics were
definitely better I mean I think Prakash
made this point of it
there should be some comparison
operation right he does have a
denotational in operational semantics
for this yeah yeah actually that was a
question I was asking Prakash over lunch
was this this idea of splitting a stream
of random choices by giving the evens to
one process and then of the rest you
give the evens to the next and so on and
are those really random and I don't know
the answer to that so if anybody does
I'd be interested to know like like it
for this domain sorry yeah well I mean
Dana's Dana's domain P of n is a
universal domain so for bounded
complaint for countably based bound
incomplete domains yeah I mean he
mentioned that the so you might ask why
do all this structure well you want you
know there's some things I didn't
mention here but what you'd like to do
is you'd like to have domains
particularly tailored to a given syntax
you might be looking at and that's
really tied up in solving what are
called domain equations solving getting
equate domains that satisfy certain
combinations of the constructs we can
use I haven't mentioned a lot of them
and that gets us back over to Samson's
domains in logical form where you can
tightly tie a logic for a domain to the
way you constructed it things like that
but you this all gets into the category
the weeds of category theory and how you
thinking about doing that but those
things I haven't talked about that's
heavily dependent on stone duality which
enters it very prominently in there so
there are a lot of ingredients that um I
left out here so I actually had a I
thought I'd write a slide of things I
left out but it got to be too long so
I saw I left it out